at the end of the day what can a person
do I mean I've had special guests at my
event I've had speakers in my event that
are black how my white supremacist I've
had my whole lineup be black speakers
the guy that got me on the show yeah I
have Jewish friends some of the people
that I cite the most in these debates
like Michael sartain's been doing his
research I know that the primary author
I cite is Jewish his name is Ron oons
the other author I cited on fresh and
fit Israel Shea Hawk is Jewish another
good friend of mine Darren Beatty runs
revolver Jewish Laura Loomer I great
personal expense people call me a
hypocrite for this I went out and
supported her and I was there on her
election night party she's a hardcore
Jewish Zionist and I happen to believe
that she's America first we disagree on
that issue but the point is is you know
all you'd have to do is take a look at
the company I keep in you know it's it's
a diverse panel